Disney's newest hip film Encanto is
about a family called The Madrigal's,
who live in an enchanted town
in the mountains of Colombia.
Now everyone except for Mirabel
has been given a magical ability.
Mirabel, the only ordinary Madrigal,
discovers that the magic is under threat
and she may be the only one able to save it.
In this film Stephanie Beatriz gives
voice to the main character: Mirabel.
She's most known for her role in Brooklyn
Nine-Nine as Detective Rosa Diaz,
we did a lesson with this show.
She is quite a fascinating
person as she was born in Argentina to a
Colombian father and a Bolivian mother.
Do you want to speak English
confidently, just like Stephanie Beatriz?
Then be sure to hit that subscribe button
and the bell below so that we can help you
to understand fast speech without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
So I know for me one of the most stressful
parts of studying a language is learning
and memorizing so many different words.
I sometimes even get anxious about whether
I'm learning the right vocabulary that I will
actually need when it comes time to speak.
Do you ever feel like this?
Well as an English learner you
are in luck because we made a course to help you
have a lot of fun learning the vocabulary that we
natives actually use every day with the TV series
Friends, which various academic studies show is
the best TV series out there for learning English.
You will also greatly improve your pronunciation
as you master connected speech and you will
laugh along with all the jokes by learning
the cultural context, so I recommend that you give
it a try for FREE now with our 3-Part Masterclass.
Just click here or in the
description below to sign up now!
In practice however it's very
common to hear people use "was".
We use the second conditional to
talk about a hypothetical situations.
"If I won a million dollars, I would..."
What would you do if you won a million
dollars? Why don't you write us down
in the comments below to practice?
And by the way, if you find conditionals
confusing or difficult we made this lesson
on our RealLife English channel to clear them up
for you, so that you can use them effortlessly.
Check it out, I'll link it
down in the description below.